[Musique]
le mag au cœur du Salon International de
l'Agriculture bonjour et bienvenue à
tous au jour de fête aujourd'hui au
salon les résultats du concours général
agricole sont tombés et la réunion peut
se réjouir elle obtient 26 médailles
contre 18 l'an passé les Roms les
confitures le miel l'excellence et les
savoir-faire de la Réunion sont
récompensés reportage
26 médailles le palmarès 2023 de quoi
faire en vie 14 médailles pour les Roms
9 pour les confitures 3 pour les miels
la Réunion remporte pas moins de 8
médailles d'or des producteurs sont
ravis à l'image de 4 USA paillettes
cinquième salon première participation
au Concours Général Agricole SA
confiture est faite dit-elle d'amour et
de passion le produit qui était primé
c'est ça c'est la confiture de papaye
passion ce petit macaron là et ça
ça attire les gens et c'est une une
sorte d'assurance pour les clients donc
pour eux si si j'ai été primé c'est que
le produit excellent la première chose
c'est ah vous êtes médaillé est-ce qu'on
peut goûter le produit et après il nous
confirme que c'est bon
et c'est ça la satisfaction
également pour Teddy Boyer c'est la
première fois que la marque se déplace
sur le salon avec cette récompense il
espère étendre sa notoriété au-delà de
la réunion
sur ce produit on est vraiment sur un
produit terroir le copeaux
et avec un vrai savoir-faire rayonner
dans les arroser ça va nous permettre
fait nos produits à la vente localement
et en métropole le palmarès 2023 donne
la part belle aux produits 100% pays les
récompenses pourraient même accélérer le
développement du label porté par le
Conseil départemental l'important pour
nous notamment pour celles et ceux qui
vont rentrer dans la démarche 100%
réunion de pouvoir bénéficier la
reconnaissance 100% excellence réunion
donc ça montre aussi qu'on est en train
de tirer vers le haut la production
réunionnaise gagner en gamme et être
reconnu à l'échelle nationale à travers
notamment de ce concours général
agricole donc de quoi encourager les
demandes d'adhésion et faire rayonner un
peu plus fort l'excellence du
savoir-faire de la Réunion
deux médailles pour le miel de bonbons
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire quels
sont ces miel qui ont été récompensés
alors on a eu donc deux médailles une
médaille d'or sur le miel de fleurs de
jouvence et une médaille de bronze sur
le miel de fleurs de bois de couleur
bravo est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
comment est-ce que vous avez réagi en
apprenant cette nouvelle on était très
heureux surtout mon frère qui est donc
du coup l'apiculteur qui se donne
beaucoup de mal à faire tout ce travail
et c'est pour lui vraiment une
récompense d'un travail de longue
haleine puisque ça fait 15 ans qui qui
essaie de travailler ses miel pour avoir
vraiment des miels d'exception et tous
les ans meilleurs en tout cas alors
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
qu'est-ce qu'il fait l'exception de ce
travail et tunnel du coup c'est vrai que
on travaille au cœur du parc national on
a la chance de pouvoir mettre les ruches
dans des endroits vraiment retirés et
vraiment où on peut trouver des fleurs
vraiment exceptionnelles de la Réunion
et du coup on va travailler aussi la
texture on va essayer d'avoir des
textures vraiment très onctueuse et
c'est vrai que ce sont aussi des miels
qui sont travaillés à froid donc on
essaie de conserver le produit vraiment
le plus authentique possible est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire si c'est médailles
ouvre de nouvelles perspectives pour le
miel c'est sûr que ça fait ça nous donne
une certaine reconnaissance par rapport
aux consommateurs c'est quand même ça
donne une belle image et c'est vrai que
c'est c'est des produits qui sont assez
recherchés du coup après par la suite et
c'est quand même assez valorisant et ce
sont des produits 100% réunion 100%
réunion oui et donc on est assez fier du
coup de pouvoir valoriser la réunion
avec ses produits qui sont vraiment
issus de notre terroir et qui valorise
notre
identité en tout cas et avec une demande
de la belle en cours oui oui tout à fait
on a la demande de la belle elle est en
cours et on espère en tout cas pouvoir
faire
partie de ce groupe et avoir son Macao
merci beaucoup et encore bravo merci
beaucoup en tout cas
nous sommes mercredi et les allées du
salon nos des emplissent pas bien au
contraire au village réunion les indé en
bulles voyage et ce qu'on
alors nous on vient de la Martinique et
l'avion elle est excellente
surtout au niveau au bout vraiment c'est
très beau
[Musique]
depuis on passe tous les matins prendre
notre petite bière
la forme le style de bijoux et puis je
sais pas comment c'est on m'a dit que
c'était des cahiers de tortues donc
c'est très joli j'aime beaucoup de fou
c'est peu commun voilà aujourd'hui je
suis venu prendre mes analas comme
d'habitude les petites bananes mignonnes
parce qu'ici on le trouve pas les
chemins de fer que je retournerai
acheter au dernier moment pour pas les
écraser les saucisses le boucané et je
vais voir peut-être pour c'est le
hachoir de citron je voilà quand je
viens ici je repars toujours avec tout
ça
le mec c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve demain
[Musique]